[Musique]
mon épouse des lettres a beaucoup de
chance parce qu'en vieillissant je suis
en train de devenir un homme beaucoup
plus supportable qu'est ce qui vous est
posée qu'est ce qui vous a câliné la
peur de la mort la peur de la solitude
que je peux pas même concevoir un énorme
et pourtant je craque c'est michel lui
qui disait qu'il n'y avait que les cons
qui - oui et j'adore cette définition
mais ça aussi un parfum de utopisme
parce que être intelligent toute la vie
sans arrêt ça c'est très difficile pour
moi aussi moi je ne compte pas la mort
vous en avez vous avez peur oui beaucoup
et ça vient d'un fait que j'ai des idées
pré vague sur ce qui vient après c'est à
dire je ne suis pas arrivé un
conclusions ni positive ni négative
alors ce qui m'apparaît évident le plus
évident c'est une espèce de lumbres et
le limbe c'est le manque d'expression et
ça vraiment me fait horreur et peur
qu'on ne vous ne pourriez pas combattre
évidemment ce que vous ne voyez pas
c'est peut-être ça qui vous ennuie non
vous ne pourriez pas livré deux combats
en réalité puisque vous aimez ça sur la
scène et dans la vie
lavaur tarn inégal le vide qui est la
façon donc dans laquelle la mort
m'apparaît c'est quelque chose qui
manque totalement de dynamique et de
dialectique alors comme je vécus de ça
et j'aime ça fait peur quelle est votre
philosophie d'avis que c'est en tout cas
c'est mieux d'y être de ne pas y être
vous parlez toujours du phalanstère on a
l'impression que vous êtes toujours en
train de chercher en tout cas que vous
avez été en train de chercher un endroit
n'est ce pas ou vos amis
votre famille tout le monde aurait pu
vivre comme ça en communauté c'est un
rêve récurrent on a fait des milliers de
repérage maison de campagne
il serait possible de bâtir espèce de
chien
j'ai même écrit un très beau script sur
sur l'utopie de charles fournier aux
temps modernes
c'est un film que je ne suis pas réussi
à monter parce qu'ils étaient trop chers
pour l'industrie italienne est trop
économiques pour l'industrie américaine
ares annoncé peut-être j'en ferai un
musical et alors je t'appelle
naturellement un rôle naval avec toutes
mes compagnons qui sont tous ces jeunes
je me rappelle que jules renard dit une
phrase très belle sur la jeunesse sous
les 20 ans et lee on avait un temps de
15 jusqu'à 30
oui c'est très gênant effectivement
[Applaudissements]
une définition à donner de vittorio
gassman non ça c'est la seule que
vraiment je ne peux pas faire parce que
j'ai largement passé l'âge où on se
regarde au miroir je me suis regardé
pendant des années c'était une nécessité
de la profession devait connaître le
seul violon que je pouvais jouer c'est à
dire moi mais maintenant je crois que je
me connais assez pour pour pour
n'oublier et tu sais bien que l'abandon
dans le théâtre comme dans tous les arts
c'est très important moi par exemple
j'ai toujours quand j'étais jeune
j'avais déjà une technique assez
développé ma difficulté c'était
l'abandon de complètement me donner aux
émotions
j réussi un peu plus maintenant et ça
c'est le seul progrès que j'ai fait je
pense avoir une vie pas par fait plein
d'erreurs comme ça mais très très riche
je me suis jamais ennuyé j'ai vu un tas
d'expériences et en effet je voudrais
pas parler de dieu parce que ça se
sentait vraiment trop grand être profond
mais j'ai une idée vague de dieu et j'ai
seulement à cet éventuel dieu une
réponse une seule reproche à faire qui
est la durée de la vie humaine
je pense qu'elle est trop courte mais en
même temps je voudrais pas qu'il soit un
fini je voudrais simplement qu'ils
soient double c'est à dire je voudrais
avoir une vie pour pour essayer et une
vie pour jouer
[Musique]